We all experienced miscommunications. They can range from hilarious to disastrous. The actor Alan Alda, yes, that Alan Alda from Mash and the West Wing and 30 Rock wants to help us all communicate better. And I've noticed that the more empathy I have, the less annoying other people are. Now, fighting miscommunication might seem like an ironic choice. For an actor whose comedy career has been built on all the funny consequences of people misunderstanding one another.
我们都经历过沟通不畅。它们可能从搞笑变成灾难。演员阿兰·阿尔达，是的，就是出演过《陆军 Mash 医疗队》、《白宫群英》和《我为喜剧狂》的那个阿兰·阿尔达，他想帮助我们所有人都更好地沟通。我注意到，我越有同理心，别人就越不惹人烦。现在，对抗沟通不畅似乎是一个讽刺的选择，对于一个喜剧生涯建立在人们互相误解的各种搞笑后果之上的演员来说。
But more recently, Alan has shifted his focus toward helping scientists and the rest of us say what we mean, mean what we say, and listen better to one another. I take the conversation with Alan at a live event in Washington DC about his new book. If I understood you, would I have this look on my face? Alan Alder, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. I want to start by asking you about an episode in your life some years ago. You were sitting in a dentist's chair and the dentist had a very sharp instrument, a couple of inches from your mouth. What happened next?
但最近，阿兰将重心转向帮助科学家和我们其他人做到言之有物、心口如一，并更好地倾听彼此。我在华盛顿特区的一个现场活动中与阿兰进行了对话，讨论了他的新书《如果我懂你的话，我脸上的表情会是这样吗？》。阿兰·阿尔达，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。我想先问你关于你多年前生活中经历的一件事。你当时坐在牙医椅上，牙医手里拿着一个非常锋利的器械，距离你的嘴只有几英寸。接下来发生了什么？
He stuck it in and carved my gums. But before he did that, he felt it was important to check off on his list, something that he had to say to me before he did this operation. The procedure was one he had invented, and he was kind of proud of it, because he was taking out a front tooth that was kind of dead, and that would leave a socket, so he had invented this method where he would draw down some of the gum over the socket to give a blood supply while it healed, which was a nice idea. Except he felt he had to explain to me what he was going to do and he wasn't real clear about it. He had the scalpel really inches from my face and
他把它捅进来，切开了我的牙龈。但在他这么做之前，他觉得有必要核对他的清单，有些话是他在这项手术之前必须对我说。这个手术是他自己发明的，他对此有点骄傲，因为他要拔掉一颗有点坏掉的前牙，这会留下一个牙槽，所以他发明了这种方法，把牙龈的一些部分拉下来盖住牙槽，以便在伤口愈合时提供血供，这是个不错的想法。除非他觉得他必须向我解释他要做什么，但他讲得不是很清楚。他把手术刀离我的脸只有几英寸，
he said now there'll be some tethering and I said what there will be what? He said, tethering. I said, tethering, tethering, tethering. He started barking at me. And I was over the age of 50. And I should have had the nerve to say, put that knife down and tell me what you're going to do to me. And I didn't do that. I was sort of, I think I was in awe of his surgical gown and he seemed to know what he was doing.
他说现在会有一些系绳（tethering），我说什么，会有什么？他说，系绳。我说，系绳，系绳，系绳。他开始对我大喊大叫。而我已经50多岁了。我本该有胆量说，把那把刀放下，告诉我你要对我做什么。但我没有那样做。我当时有点，我想我对他的手术服感到敬畏，而且他似乎知道自己在做什么。
And so I let him go ahead and do it without knowing what he was talking about. By the way, to this day, I don't know what tethering meant in that situation. But he did the procedure and I was making a movie a couple of weeks later and I had a smile in the scene so I gave this big, hearty smile and after the shot was over the director photography said I thought you were going to smile. I said I did, he said no you were sneering. He said no I wasn't, he said go look the mirror. And I looked in the mirror and I smiled. And I was sneering. So he had done something. He cut off that little tissue between your upper lip and your gum.
所以我任由他继续做下去，却根本不知道他在说什么。顺便说一句，直到今天，我也不知道在那种情况下“系绳”是什么意思。但他做了这个手术，几周后我在拍一部电影，我在一个镜头里笑了，所以我露出了一个灿烂、爽朗的微笑，镜头拍完后，摄影指导说我以为你要笑。我说我笑了，他说不，你是在假笑。我说不，我没有，他说去照镜子。我照了照镜子，笑了。我确实在假笑。所以他做了点什么。他切断了你上唇和牙龈之间那小块组织。
And my lip just sort of hung there. But the only good thing about that was that I was able to play a whole range of villains really well. But I, you know, it's interesting. There was another example in that situation of not great communicating because I called him and told him that what had happened and that I was disappointed and he started getting very defensive. Never said I'm sorry that you felt mutilated. In fact, he said, I told you there were two steps
而我的嘴唇就那样耷拉着。但唯一的好处是，我能把各种各样的反派角色演得很好。但我，你知道，这很有趣。那种情况下还有另一个沟通不佳的例子，因为我打电话告诉他发生了什么事，我很失望，而他开始变得非常防备。从来没说过“很遗憾让你感觉被残害了”。事实上，他说，我告诉过你手术分两步。
to the procedure. I don't really remember if I went back for another step, I was afraid to let him in again. But then he sent me a letter telling me why he wasn't responsible for anything. It was a defensive letter that set him up for his defense in case I sued him. And I had no intention of suing him. It's wanted him to know that one of his customers wasn't happy. I was driving over in an Uber on my way here, Alan, and I must have found the most aggressive Uber driver in Washington. Driving in Washington, D.C. at about 5.45 in the evening is one of the worst experiences on the planet, but this Uber driver was really aggressive and cutting people off and driving really recklessly.
我不记得自己是否回去做了第二步，我太害怕让他再碰我了。但随后他给我寄了一封信，告诉我他为什么不对任何事情负责。那是一封防御性的信，为他万一我起诉他做好了辩护准备。而我根本没有起诉他的打算。我只是想让他知道他的一个客户很不高兴。我坐着优步赶往这里的路上，阿兰，我一定在华盛顿遇到了最激进的优步司机。傍晚5点45分左右在华盛顿特区开车是地球上最糟糕的体验之一，但这个优步司机真的非常激进，强行超车，开车非常鲁莽。
And I kept thinking, what would Alan Alder tell me? What should I say? And I felt it was not my place to be telling her how to drive. At the same time, I felt like my life was in danger. And I felt I was wrong in keeping quiet. And then we were on 15th Street about a block away. And she made this turn at somewhat high speed, and she missed a bicycle by maybe a couple of inches.
我一直在想，阿兰·阿尔达会告诉我什么？我该说些什么？我觉得告诉她怎么开车不关我的事。与此同时，我觉得我的生命受到了威胁。我觉得自己保持沉默是错的。然后我们在15街，大约一个街区远的地方。她以相当高的速度转了这个弯，距离一辆自行车可能只有几英寸。
And it made me think about your story about the tethering, which is we keep silent in all kinds of situations. Yes, that's true. And it really is a good idea to get alert to what you're feeling and give voice to it. And I think if you give voice to it. And I think if you give voice to it with what the other person is hearing in mind, it doesn't have to be aggressive. You don't have to say, don't drive badly like that.
这让我想起了你关于“系绳”的故事，也就是说我们在各种情况下都保持沉默。是的，这千真万确。对自己的感受保持警觉并说出来，这确实是个好主意。而且我认为，如果你把感受说出来时，心里想着对方会听到什么，这就不一定具有攻击性。你不必说，别开得这么烂。
You could put it in your terms. It's, you're making me crazy. In 1993, you began hosting this show for PBS, where you interviewed various scientists, scientific, American frontiers, it was called. And in one of your earlier stories, this might even have been your first story, you interviewed a scientist who was building a solar powered racing car. And right out of the box, you made three communication blunders. I know, it was my first interview and I had talked my way into the show.
你可以用你自己的方式表达。那就是，你快把我逼疯了。1993年，你开始为公共电视网（PBS）主持这个节目，采访各种科学家，节目名叫《科学美国前沿》。在你的早期故事之一中，这甚至可能是你的第一个故事，你采访了一位正在建造太阳能赛车的科学家。一上手，你就犯了三个沟通错误。我知道，这是我的第一次采访，我是自己毛遂自荐加入这个节目的。
They said, we want you to host the show and I thought, oh, they just want me to read a narration but I want to talk to the scientist's son, Camer, so I can learn about their work. And I had done a little interviewing, taking over as a guest host once in a while, but I had an interview with scientists before. So they took a real chance on me when they said they'd do it.
他们说，我们想让你主持节目，我想，哦，他们只是想让我读一段旁白，但我想和科学家的儿子卡梅尔（Camer）谈谈，这样我就可以了解他们的工作。我以前做过一点采访，偶尔客串过几次主持人，但我以前从来没有采访过科学家。所以当他们说同意时，真的是在我身上冒了个大险。
And there was the scientist with a solar panel, and I just hesitated for a moment before I went in, and the producer said, go ahead, go in there, this is what you want, right? So I went in and you're right, I made three blunders right off the bat. First of all, I told him something that wasn't true about his own work. I said, this is amazing how you've built the solar panel using entirely parts off the shelf.
当时那位科学家和他的太阳能电池板就在那儿，我在进去之前犹豫了一会儿，制作人说，去吧，进去吧，这正是你想要的，对吧？所以我进去了，你说得对，我一上来就犯了三个错误。首先，我告诉了他关于他自己的工作的一件不真实的事情。我说，你完全使用现成的零件制造了这块太阳能电池板，这太惊人了。
I don't know what made me think that I was done that way. And I saw this pained look on his face and he said, it wasn't off the shelf. Some of these were made with great care. So I felt a little abashed at that and I wanted to make up for it. So I wanted to show how familiar and tenderly I felt toward little abashed at that, and I wanted to make up for it, so I wanted to show how familiar and tenderly I felt toward his work, and I rested my hand on his solar panel. He said, don't touch that, you could break it. And then I realized I was making the third blunder about halfway through.
我不知道是什么让我觉得它是那样制作的。我看到他脸上痛苦的表情，他说，这不是现成的。其中一些是用巨大的心血制作的。所以我对此感到有点窘迫，我想弥补。所以我想表现出我对他的工作是多么熟悉和充满温情，我把手搭在了他的太阳能电池板上。他说，别碰那个，你会把它弄坏的。然后我意识到我进行到一半时犯了第三个错误。
I wasn't asking him questions based on what he had just said to me. I was asking him questions based on what I had intended earlier to ask him. So it was almost in danger of getting into that situation where the interviewer says, how's everything going? And you say, my grandmother just died and the interviewer says, great. Now tell me about your last movie. You know, you've got to respond to where the person really is and they were good blunders to make because I could see right, right away that I needed, I needed to relate better to the people I was going to be talking with. So it turns out Alan, you haven't just made blunders talking to scientists. You have made blunders talking to your own relatives.
我没有根据他刚才对我说的话向他提问。我问他的问题是基于我之前打算问他的问题。所以这几乎陷入了那种境地：采访者问，最近怎么样？你说，我奶奶刚去世，采访者说，太棒了。现在跟我聊聊你的上一部电影。你知道的，你必须根据当事人真实的处境作出反应，这些都是很好的错误，因为我立刻看出我需要，我需要与我要交谈的人建立更好的联系。事实证明，阿兰，你不只是在和科学家对话时犯过糊涂。你在和自己的亲戚对话时也犯过糊涂。
I'm making my blunder right now talking to you. LAUGHTER You tell the story in your book about being on a vacation with your six-year-old grandson in the Virgin Islands. And he spotted this very unusual looking tree, and he asked you how it came to be that way. That's right, because we had never seen these trees and bushes and plants that we were seeing on this walk, because the Virgin Islands is such a paradise and it has so many different kinds of vegetation.
我正在跟你说话，这就犯了个糊涂。笑声你在书里讲了这样一个故事：有一次你带着6岁的孙子在美属维尔京群岛度假。他发现了这棵长相非常奇特的树，他问你是怎么长成那样的。没错，因为我们在这次散步中看到的这些树木、灌木和植物，我们以前从未见过，因为美属维尔京群岛简直是人间天堂，有着那么多不同种类的植被。
So we saw this tree that had a long skinny trunk with spikes all up and down it. It looked like a dragon's back. And Teo said, Cranpa, look at that tree, how did it get like that? And I thought, oh, this is great. He's asking me about evolution. We can have a talk about evolution. He was only six years old, but he's asking me this question that I can I can we can really have this great conversation. So we sat on the ground and We talked about evolution for 45 minutes Who is glorious natural selection the whole thing and the next day he was swimming with his cousin and he asked her a question and she said he was swimming with his cousin, and he asked her a question, and she said, well, that sounds like a science question.
所以我们看到了一棵树，它有着长而细的树干，上面长满了刺。它看起来像龙的脊背。特奥说，爷爷，看那棵树，它是怎么长成那样的？我想，哦，太棒了。他在问我关于进化论的问题。我们可以聊聊进化论。他当时才六岁，但他问了我这个问题，我可以，我们可以真正进行一次非常棒的对话。于是我们坐在地上，聊了45分钟的进化论。这是光荣的自然选择，整个过程。第二天，他和表妹一起游泳时，他问了她一个问题，她说，他当时和表妹一起游泳，他问了她一个问题，她说，嗯，听起来像是个科学问题。
Why don't you ask grandpa? He said, I'm not making that mistake, I agree. I'm a font of blunders. I'm talking with Alan Alder about the high cost of miscommunication and what we can do to become better communicators. When we come back, we're going to look at some scenes from Alan's acting career that illustrate important ideas related to communication. Stay with us. I want to play you some clips from your acting career that I think reveals some interesting questions and themes related to communication. This first one comes from Mash, where you played a character named Hawkeye Pierce.
你为什么不问爷爷？他说，我可不犯第二次傻，我同意。我简直就是个错误制造机。我正在与阿兰·阿尔达探讨沟通不畅的高昂代价，以及我们如何才能成为更好的沟通者。广告回来后，我们将回顾阿兰演艺生涯中的一些片段，这些片段阐述了与沟通相关的重要理念。请不要走开。我想播放一些你演艺生涯中的剪辑片段，我认为这些片段揭示了一些与沟通相关的有趣问题和主题。第一个片段来自《Mash》，你在其中饰演一个名叫鹰眼·皮尔斯的角色。
And I want to play the clip and then ask you a question. And carefully cut the wires leading to the clock work used at the head. But first, remove the fuse. You've spent much of your career, Alan, working in scenes which involve comedic timing. And I want to talk a little bit about the idea of timing in communication. Have the skills that you learned as an actor, your timing skills,
我想播放这个片段，然后问你一个问题。并小心翼翼地切断通往头部时钟机构的导线。但首先，要拆掉保险丝。阿兰，你的大部分职业生涯都在参与涉及喜剧节奏的场景。我想谈谈沟通中节奏的概念。你作为演员学到的技能，你的节奏感，
helped you in your actual life. Has it helped you in your relationships in terms of what you say, knowing what the right time is to bring something up? Everything I learned as an actor, it turns out, has been important to me in this phase in my life when I'm trying to help people communicate better. And when I'm trying to learn myself out of communicate better, timing for me goes like this.
对你的实际生活有帮助吗？它在你说什么话、知道什么时候是提出某事的绝佳时机方面，对你的人际关系有帮助吗？事实证明，我作为演员学到的一切，在我现在这个试图帮助人们更好地沟通的人生阶段，都对我至关重要。当我试图自己学习如何更好地沟通时，对我的节奏感来说是这样的。
There are many people who think timing is waiting before you get to the punch line. And some people actually think that you're supposed to count to three silently before you do the punch line or some other number. For me, timing has always meant a thought process that you're going through and at the end of that thought, that's when the punch line comes out. Either you're trying to figure something out, or something, there's some internal conflict, and something arises from the unconscious, and that's when you say what it is.
很多人认为节奏就是在抖包袱（punch line）之前等待。有些人甚至认为你在抖包袱之前应该默数到三，或者其他某个数字。对我来说，节奏一直意味着你正在经历的一个思维过程，而在那个思想结束时，包袱就抖出来了。要么你正在弄明白某事，或者有什么内部冲突出现，然后某种东西从潜意识中浮现，那就是你道出真相的时候。
It's not a simple thing. It's not, timing is not waiting. Timing is actually going through something, and what you go through is different from time to time. But that's kind of technical and it's part, it's based on the idea that for me anyway, the best kind of acting is going through an experience that's very similar to real life. And the time it takes to say something is dependent upon the circumstance you're in and your response to it. So when you say you go through this thought process as you're telling a joke an audience, then you're really aware of
这不是一件简单的事。节奏不是等待。节奏实际上是经历某事，而你所经历的事情每次都不一样。但这有点技术性，而且它基于这样一种观点——无论如何对我来说——最好的表演方式是经历一段与现实生活非常相似的体验。说一句话所需的时间取决于你所处的环境以及你对它的反应。所以当你对着观众讲笑话时，你说你经历了这种思维过程，那么你其实非常清楚
what they're going through moment by moment, and you're aware of their thought process to a great extent. If you're acting with another actor, the thought process is the interaction between you and the other actor. You don't spray your dialogue at the other person. It's really important, this idea, that I don't say my next line in a play, because it's written in the script, and I've memorized it. I say it because you do something, you the other actor, do something, or you say something, that makes me say this next line, and makes me say it in a certain way. You know, you spend some time as a science journalist, Alan, and I actually have spent
他们时刻在经历着什么，并且在很大程度上了解他们的思维过程。如果你在和另一个演员演对手戏，思维过程就是你和另一个演员之间的互动。你不是把台词像喷雾一样喷向对方。这个想法非常重要：我在戏剧中不念下一句台词，仅仅是因为它写在剧本里，而且我已经背熟了。我说它是是因为你做了某事，你这个演员做了某事，或者你说了某事，促使我说出这下一句台词，并促使我以某种特定方式说出来。阿兰，你曾当过一段时间的科学记者，而我其实当过非常短暂的一段时间演员，直到我意识到我根本不是干这块料的。不是吧。是的，但其中有一点……
some time very briefly as an actor before I realized that this was not cut out for me at all. No kidding. Yeah, but one of the things... Comedic timing, ladies and gentlemen. But one of the things I was always surprised by is when director said you really have to listen to what the other person is saying and it always struck me as odd because this is a script.
女士们先生们，喜剧节奏。但让我一直感到惊讶的一件事是，当导演说你真的必须倾听对方在说什么时，这让我觉得很奇怪，因为这是剧本。
Everyone's saying their lines. You know what you're going to say. Why do you have to go? I think this explains your exit from that to the end. But that's the heart of it. That's really the heart of my book. The idea that you must listen to the other actor is so fundamental to me that that's in a way the essence of it. You can't have spontaneity. It's not going to
每个人都在说他们的台词。你知道你要说什么。为什么你必须去……我想这解释了你从那行退出的原因。但这才是核心所在。这真的是我书的核心。必须倾听另一个演员的意见这个想法对我来说太基础了，在某种程度上这就是它的本质。你不可能拥有即兴发挥。如果我没有倾听你并对你做出反应，
look like life happening between us if I'm not listening to you and responding to you. This next clip I want to play for you Alan actually I think speaks to what you're just talking about because it talks a little bit about how people listen to one another and this comes from 30 Rock. You're speaking in this scene with Alec Baldwin, and I'll let the clip do the talking. Do you remember a woman named Colleen Donoggi? Sure. That takes me back a few years. 1958?
它看起来就不会像我们之间正在发生的生活。阿兰，我想为你播放的下一个片段，实际上我认为它正切中了你刚才谈论的话题，因为它谈到了一点人们是如何互相倾听的，这个片段来自《我为喜剧狂》。你在这一幕中与亚历克·鲍德温对话，我就让片段本身来说话吧。你还记得一个叫科琳·多诺吉的女人吗？当然。这让我回想起好几年前。1958年？
Yeah, right. She rented me a room when I was a graduate student. One month I couldn't pay, so she said maybe there was something else I could give her. So I gave her my radio. Then a couple of weeks later we got drunk and had sex. Oh, OK. I'm Jack Donoghie, Colleen's son. I was born around nine months after that.
是的，没错。我读研究生时，她租给我一个房间。有一个月我付不起房租，所以她说也许还有别的东西我可以给她。所以我把收音机给了她。然后几周后我们喝醉了发生了性关系。哦，好吧。我是杰克·多诺吉，科琳的儿子。我大约在那之后九个月出生。
Oh, my God. Wait a minute. Is this contest some mama me, is thing? Milton. I'm your son. Who is your wife? I shouldn't have known the minute I saw you. Oh, thank you, I was son! Oh, pure son! Can I have a death? They just brought us together, Jack. They'll open a whole new chapter in my life.
哦，天哪。等等。这场竞赛是一场“妈妈咪呀”式的寻亲吗？米尔顿。我是你儿子。谁是你妻子？我一看到你就该知道了。哦，谢谢你，我是个儿子！噢，纯粹的儿子！我能要个肾吗？他们把我们聚在一起，杰克。他们将开启我生活中的全新篇章。
Yeah, isn't it amazing? You don't know the half of it! I need a kidney. So I love that scene. But I also love it not just because it's funny, because I think it illustrates an idea that researchers have talked about for a while. This idea called switch tracking, which is that when you're having a conversation with people,
是啊，不是很神奇吗？你根本不懂其中的深意！我需要一个肾。所以我喜欢那一幕。但我也喜欢它，不仅仅是因为它很有趣，还因为它阐明了一个研究人员讨论了一段时间的想法。这个想法被称为“频道切换”（switch tracking），也就是说，当你和别人交谈时，
sometimes both people can think they're having a conversation, but they're actually having two different conversations. Yeah, and I agree. That's what's happening in this scene. Alec Baldwin's character thinks he's found his father and that it means something to both of them as it does to him. And he just realized to father just once a kidney.
有时候双方都以为自己在进行同一次对话，但实际上他们在进行两种不同的对话。是的，我同意。这就是这一幕中正在发生的事情。亚历克·鲍德温饰演的角色以为他找到了父亲，这对他们两个都有意义，对他来说确实如此。而他刚刚意识到父亲只想要一个肾。
So he's glad to find his son. But that you're right. That happens in less comedic ways and sometimes in tragic ways in real life where we think we're on the same track and we're really not. If you're really on two different tracks, you'll actually see in the other person's face that things aren't really driving here. There are points where contact is missing and they'll start to look confused or upset at certain points because you know you'll be answering the wrong questions. Right. Or not reading the subtext of the questions.
所以他很高兴找到他的儿子。但你说得对。在现实生活中，这种现象会以不那么喜剧的方式、有时甚至是悲剧性的方式发生，我们以为我们在同一个频道上，但实际上并没有。如果你真的在两个不同的频道上，你实际上会从对方的脸上看出事情在这里并没有真正推进。在某些时刻，接触会缺失，他们会开始显得困惑或不安，因为你知道你会回答错误的问题。对的。或者没有解读出问题背后的潜台词。
Right. The question is not actually what it seems to be. It's actually something else. Which is probably the most common way you're on two different tracks. You're not noticing the subtext. Right. I want to play you a third clip. This one comes from...
对的。问题实际上并不像表面看起来的那样。它其实是另外一回事。这可能是你身处两个不同频道的最常见方式。你没有注意到潜台词。对的。我想放第三个片段给你看。这个来自……
Keep them coming. I love watching this one. This one comes from the West Wing and the setup here is that two presidential candidates are about to walk on stage for a debate. Next time you decide to smear me, maybe you'll have the guts to do it yourself? I didn't think to do it that way. You blow up the debate. It's clear what kind of a campaign you want. I forgot how eager you were for debates. And next time you send left-wing lobbyists to my office, don't forget the gift card. You want another campaign you're going to get one.
尽管放吧。我喜欢看这个。这个来自《白宫群英》，这里的设定是两位总统候选人即将走上舞台进行辩论。下次你决定抹黑我的时候，也许你会有种自己动手？我没想到要这么做。你把辩论搞砸了。很清楚你想进行什么样的竞选。我忘了你对辩论是多么渴望。下次你派左翼游说者去我办公室时，别忘了带礼品卡。你想再来一场竞选，你会如愿以偿的。
I didn't start this. Now, you had to amend it before you. Thank you for being here. You're hitting me on a partial breath tonight, aren't you? Our next guest is served with enormous things that are centred from the gold-based. New year. Presidential campaign, green national debate. Pounding each other. And one of the few things we basically agree.
我可没挑起这个。现在，你必须在……之前修改它。谢谢你们来到这里。今晚你对我进行了部分打击，不是吗？我们的下一位嘉宾受到了来自黄金基础的大量表彰。新年。总统竞选，绿色国家辩论。互相猛烈抨击。这是我们基本上达成一致的少数几件事之一。
I want to ask you about the present political moment, Alan, not so much about what's happening specifically with people in Washington or what's happening in the news, but really about the moment that we're living in, where it feels like there is so much anger and vitriol on both sides of the aisle. And I'm wondering whether some of it actually has to do with what's happening here, which is a lot of Americans might actually not have significant differences of opinion. I mean, we might disagree with things. You might think 5% of the budget needs to be for education,
阿兰，我想问你关于当前的政治时刻，不是关于华盛顿特区的人们具体发生了什么，也不是新闻里发生了什么，而是关于我们生活的这个时刻，在这个时刻，感觉两党之间有那么多的愤怒和恶毒。我想知道其中一部分是否实际上与这里发生的事情有关，那就是很多美国人的意见可能实际上并没有重大分歧。我的意思是，我们可能会在某些事情上有分歧。你可能认为预算的5%需要用于教育，
and I think it's 8% of the budget. But we're not actually casms apart in terms of our views. But the partisan rancor that we have makes us feel as if we actually are, you know, poles apart. And I'm wondering, is this a communication question? Is part of the anger that we feel to one another in the country, driven by a kind of miscommunication in some ways, where we're not reading each other correctly,
而我认为是预算的8%。但在我们的观点方面，我们实际上并不是鸿沟巨大。但我们拥有的党派积怨让我们觉得，你知道的，我们实际上相隔十万八千里。我想知道，这是一个沟通问题吗？我们在国内对彼此感受到的一部分愤怒，在某种程度上是否是由某种沟通不畅驱动的，我们在这种沟通不畅中没有正确解读对方，
and we're seeing the worst in each other. I think you're probably right. And what interests me about you're choosing this clip and playing it right after the previous clip, is this is almost a mirror image of the other clip where they're having two different conversations. They mean two different things by the same conversation.
并且把对方想得最坏。我想你可能是对的。最让我感兴趣的是，你选择这个片段并在前一个片段之后立即播放它，这几乎是另一个片段的镜像，他们在那里进行着两种不同的对话。对于同一场对话，他们有着两种不同的含义。
And these two people have the opposite problem. They basically are in agreement and have to fight, nevertheless. And we are preparing to fight. They're ready to go out and tear each other to pieces. And partly, I think, because they belong to two different tribes, and those tribes have been feuding for a long time. And there isn't much incentive, although there used to be, it seems, though, was more incentive to find out the common ground, which could solve a lot of these problems. It's so interesting.
而这两个人有相反的问题。他们基本上是一致的，然而却不得不打仗。我们正在准备开战。他们准备好走出去把对方撕成碎片。部分原因，我认为，是因为他们属于两个不同的部落，而这些部落已经争斗了很长时间。而且没有太多的动力——尽管过去似乎有过——去找出可以解决其中很多问题的共同点，似乎动力更多了。太有趣了。
I talk about in the book some extreme examples of people at each other's throats, like the Transwar Fair in World War I. When on Christmas Eve, they realized they had common ground when they heard each other singing Christmas carols across No Man's land. And the next morning on Christmas Day, they got up out of their trenches and met in No Man's land.
我在书中谈到了一些人们剑拔弩张的极端例子，比如第一次世界大战中的圣诞停战。当他们在平安夜听到彼此在无人区对面唱圣诞颂歌时，他们意识到他们有共同点。第二天圣诞节早上，他们爬出战壕，在无人区相遇。
Shook hands, some of them played soccer. They got to know one another. And then the officers came and said, there's supposed to be a war happening here. And they went back into trenches and tried to kill each other again. But for that moment they had the common ground. You know, I'm thinking about the days right after the 9-11 attacks in the United States, where it felt for a week or two that there was an enormous sense of unity. And again, it was sort of, I guess it's
握手，其中一些人踢了足球。他们了解了彼此。然后军官们走过来，说，这里应该有一场战争。他们又回到了战壕里，试图互相杀死对方。但在那一刻，他们拥有了共同点。你知道，我在想美国9-11袭击之后的几天，感觉有一两周时间有一种巨大的团结感。而且，再次，这有点，我想它
not quite the same thing, but it's the idea that there's something, the frame shift sometimes. And you stop seeing yourself as Republicans and Democrats, but you start seeing yourself as part of a larger group. That's the way it's supposed to be. There's supposed to be Republicans and Democrats in order to function well as part of a larger group, which is called the United States of America. And that's sometimes secondary to aiding your party. That's an unfortunate thing because in the long run, it's very costly.
不完全是一回事，但它是那种东西的概念，框架有时会发生转变。你不再把自己视为共和党人和民主党人，而是开始把自己视为一个更大群体的一部分。事情本该如此。为了作为一个更大群体（被称为美利坚合众国）的一部分而良好运作，本该存在共和党人和民主党人。而这有时会屈居于协助你的政党之后。这是一件不幸的事情，因为从长远来看，代价非常高昂。
I'm talking with Alan Alder before a live audience in Washington, DC. When we come back, I'm going to ask Alan about some techniques that actors learn that can help us all become better communicators. Stay with us. Applause. Applause.
我在华盛顿特区当着现场观众的面与阿兰·阿尔达交谈。广告回来后，我将向阿兰询问一些演员学习的技巧，这些技巧可以帮助我们所有人都成为更好的沟通者。请不要走开。掌声。掌声。
Applause. Applause. I want to talk about another situation involving a doctor. This one involved a doctor, I believe, in Chile, where you needed medical attention. And this doctor treated you very differently than the dentist treated you in the other situation. That's true. It was the best example of communication I had ever heard. I had, my problem was that I had an intestine that had twisted, got caught in something, and
掌声。掌声。我想谈谈另一个涉及医生的情景。这个涉及一位医生，我相信是在智利，当时你需要医疗救助。这位医生对你的治疗方式与另一个情景中牙医对你的治疗方式截然不同。的确如此。这是我听过的最好的沟通例子。我的问题是，我的肠子扭转了，卡在什么东西里了，
had choked off the blood supply. And about a yard of my intestine was dying. And in the middle of the night I was taken to a hospital, and he recognized almost immediately what was wrong with me. And he didn't use fancy language. He explained to me in the simplest, the simplest language. Here's what's happened, he said. Some of your intestine has gone bad.
并且切断了血液供应。我大约一码长的肠子正在坏死。半夜我被送到医院，他几乎立刻就认出了我出了什么毛病。他没有用花哨的语言。他用最简单、最简单的语言向我解释。他说，事情是这样的。你的一些肠子坏了。
And we have to cut out the bed part and sew the two good ends together. You can't get simpler than that. And that was absolutely accurate. There wasn't anything about that as clear as it was. There wasn't true. And by the way, he wasn't just speaking clearly. I remember so vividly, his leaning down, looking into my eyes, watching my face to see if I understood him. That was the essence of good communication. He was watching me to see if I was getting it. Did I understand him or did I have that funny look on my face?
我们必须把坏掉的部分切断，把两个好的端部缝合在一起。没有比这更简单的了。而且绝对准确。尽管它非常清晰，但其中没有任何一点不是事实。顺便说一句，他不仅说话清晰。我记得非常生动的是，他俯下身来，看着我的眼睛，观察我的脸，看我是否听懂了他的话。这就是良好沟通的本质。他看着我，看我是否听明白了。我听懂了吗，还是我脸上露出了那种滑稽的表情？
And he had the answer to your original notion is, things I've learned as an actor have made me understand the importance of how that doctor Nelson Zapata in Chile and the middle of the night, 13 or 14 years ago, how he made a real effort to communicate with me and it made all the difference for me. I understand the technical term for this procedure is an end-to-end enastomosis, if I'm saying that correctly. And I can just imagine the doctor had said,
他找到了你最初想法的答案：我作为演员学到的东西让我明白了那位医生——13或14年前半夜在智利的尼尔森·萨帕塔（Nelson Zapata）——如何努力与我沟通的重要性，这对我产生了深远的影响。我了解到这个手术的专业术语是端端吻合术（end-to-end anastomosis），如果我没说错的话。我简直可以想象，如果医生说，
I'm going to perform an end-to-end enastomosis, Mr. Alder, how that would have made you feel. Well, I would have felt the way I did with the dentist. I want to ask you about another thing you mentioned in the book. You cite Don Hewitt, who was the creator of the television show, 60 Minutes. And you say that Don had a simple, forward question. He would ask when people pitch stories for the show that in some ways was the essence of the success of the show.
阿尔达先生，我要为你做一个端端吻合术，你当时会有什么感觉。嗯，我会觉得和那个牙医在一起时的感觉一样。我想问你书里提到的另一件事。你引用了电视节目《60分钟》的创作者唐·休伊特（Don Hewitt）的话。你说唐有一个简单直接的问题，当人们为节目推介故事时，他会问这个问题，这在某种程度上是该节目成功的精髓。
Yes, he loved that story, and I know he loved it because I knew Don for about 30 years, and he told me that story three times a year. And the story was that when somebody would come into his office, a producer, and say, I got a great idea for a segment on the show, they'd start to tell about some infraction of the banking regulations
是的，他喜欢那个故事，我知道他喜欢，因为我认识唐大约30年了，他一年把那个故事讲了三遍。那个故事是，当有人走进他的办公室，一个制作人说，我对节目里的一个环节有个绝妙的主意，他们开始讲述一些违反银行法规的事情
or something like that. He'd hold up his anisei, wait a minute. Forwards, tell me a story. And he felt that that was what made the show so successful. All those years it was number one for a couple of decades, at least. And I think he was right about it being due to the part of the success of the show. And I think it's because we all tell stories to one another. We listen better to a story. We get involved when we hear a story. And his stories would always have a middle part where the fortunes shifted and you thought to yourself, this isn't what I thought this was going to be about, this is a deeper question.
诸如此类的事。他会举起手说，等一下。言归正传，给我讲个故事。他觉得正是这一点让这个节目如此成功。在那些年里，它连续几十年位居第一。我想他在节目成功的一部分原因上是正确的。我想这是因为我们都会互相讲故事。我们能更好地倾听一个故事。当我们听到故事时，我们会融入其中。他的故事总是有一个中间部分，在这个部分中命运发生了逆转，你会想，这不是我想象的那样，这是一个更深层的问题。
Or this look at the turn this took, now this is affecting me in a different way. The importance of the middle, I think, is so huge. You know, I was interviewing a researcher at Columbia University, her name is Shaodong Lin, and she's done a lot of work looking at trying to get children interested in science. And she finds that something really fascinating that speaks to exactly what you just talked about,
或者看看事情发生的转变，现在这正以一种不同的方式影响着我。我认为中间部分的重要性太巨大了。你知道，我当时在采访哥伦比亚大学的一位研究人员，她的名字叫林少东（Shaodong Lin），她做了大量工作，试图让孩子们对科学产生兴趣。她发现了一件非常迷人的事情，恰好印证了你刚才所说的话，
which is the traditional way we have of teaching science, is to tell people, you know, there was this great physicist, Albert Einstein, and he was the greatest genius the world has ever known and he came up with theories that even today many people struggle to understand. So that's the classic way we tell science stories. And what she found was that instead of doing that, if you tell a story which says something along the lines of, you know, there was a time when Einstein was working on a problem and he got so stuck that he couldn't figure out the math and he needed help to figure out the math and he reached out to somebody
也就是说，我们传统的科学教学方式是告诉人们，你知道，有这样一位伟大的物理学家，阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦，他是世界上有史以来最伟大的天才，他提出的理论即使在今天许多人也难以理解。所以这是我们讲述科学故事的经典方式。而她发现，与其那样做，如果你讲一个这样的故事：你知道，有一次爱因斯坦正在研究一个问题，他卡住了，甚至算不出数学题，他需要帮助才能算出数学题，于是他向别人求助，
else saying, I can't figure out the math to this, can you please help me? When you tell stories that involve struggle and obstacles and failures about scientists, not only does this whole people's attention, but kids are now able to say, I can see myself being a scientist because I need help with math. I turn to somebody else to get help from math. And this idea that the obstacle in some ways is what makes the story the story is, I think, what you mean by the middle. It is. And underneath all of that is trying to be aware of what the listener is going through while you tell them about this, because you might have the best message in the world, and a lot of people think good communication is devising a really good message that's logical, clear, clear to you anyway.
说，我解不出这个数学题，你能帮帮我吗？当你讲述涉及科学家奋斗、障碍和失败的故事时，这不仅吸引了人们的注意力，而且孩子们现在能够说，我能看到自己成为一名科学家的可能，因为我也需要数学方面的帮助。我向其他人寻求数学方面的帮助。这种认为障碍在某种程度上使故事成为故事的想法，我认为就是你所说的“中间部分”。确实如此。而在这一切的背后，是试图意识到听众在你向他们讲述这些时正在经历什么，因为你可能拥有世界上最好的信息，许多人认为良好的沟通就是设计一个逻辑清晰、对你来说无论如何都很清晰的好信息。
The question is how clear is it and how interesting is it to the person you're trying to tell it to or the the layer of the public you're trying to tell it to. If you can imagine what they're going through while they hear your story, then you're relating to them in the same way that I found I related to the other actor when I was on the stage. One of the really interesting things you did was you have brought in groups of engineering students and other technical people and you have taught them improv. You've taught them, you've put them through three hours of improv games. Why in the world would you do that? Because when I left the science show, I realized that the reason that the show
问题是，对于你试图讲述的对象或你试图讲述的公众层面来说，它有多清晰，有多有趣。如果你能想象他们在听到你的故事时正在经历什么，那么你就以与我在舞台上发现自己与另一个演员产生联系的同样方式与他们建立了联系。你做的非常有趣的事情之一是，你把工程专业的学生和其他技术人员的小组请来，教他们即兴表演。你教过他们，让他们经历了三个小时的即兴游戏。你到底为什么要这么做？因为当我离开科学节目时，我意识到节目之所以
worked was because we had a real connection between us. It wasn't an ordinary interview. I never went in with the set of questions, not after the beginning. I went in just being curious and really good and ignorant. It's good to be ignorant as long as you're curious. Not so good if you're not curious. So I would be willing to reveal my ignorance to them so they knew where I was in my understanding of their work. And then if I didn't understand what they were saying, I'd grab them by the lapels and shake them. I'd just tell me again. So they forgot about the camera. They forgot about the lectures they had given on this.
行得通，是因为我们之间有真正的联系。这不是一次普通的采访。我从来没有带着一整套问题去过，一开始之后就再也没有了。我带着好奇、真正的好奇和无知去。只要你保持好奇，无知是一件好事。如果你不好奇，那就不太妙了。所以我愿意向他们暴露我的无知，让他们知道我对他们工作的理解处于什么水平。然后，如果我不明白他们在说什么，我会抓住他们的翻领摇晃他们。我会让他们再讲一遍。于是他们忘记了摄像机。他们忘记了他们关于这方面的演讲。
They were just trying to make me understand it. And I realized that what I was doing was relating to them, and they were relating to me in the same way two actors do, where they let each other in to their field of consciousness. So I thought the best way to train people to do that is through improvisation training. And I tried it out with a group of engineers.
他们只是试图让我理解它。我意识到我所做的是在与他们建立联系，而他们也在以两个演员在舞台上允许彼此进入各自意识领域的方式与我建立联系。所以我想训练人们这样做的最好方法是通过即兴表演训练。我在一组工程师身上进行了尝试。
And after three hours, there was so much better talking about their work. I thought, I think we got something here. We can make this work as the basis of training. And soon after that, we started what's now known as the Allen Aldecentre for Communicating Science at Stony Brook University in New York. And we've taught, in the past eight years,
三个小时后，他们在谈论自己的工作时表现得好多了。我想，我觉得我们在这里掌握了诀窍。我们可以让它作为培训的基础发挥作用。在那之后不久，我们创立了现在被称为纽约州立大学石溪分校阿兰·阿尔达科学传播中心（The Alan Alda Center for Communicating Science）的机构。在过去的八年里，
we've taught almost 10,000 scientists and doctors to communicate better, starting with classes and improvisation, and then moving on to working out the content of what they're going to say. The thing is, if you really relate to the other person, that has an effect on the content of what you're going to say to them. You're not going to use certain words. You're not going to use certain concepts.
我们已经培训了近10000名科学家和医生更好地沟通，从即兴表演课程开始，然后转向打磨他们要表达的内容。关键在于，如果你真的与对方建立联系，这会对你要对他们说的话的内容产生影响。你不会使用某些词。你不会使用某些概念。
You're going to make sure they're with you along the way. You have a wonderful story in your book about a moment you were trying to catch a cab. And one of the things that I didn't know about you is apparently in your 20s, among the many, many things you've done in your life, you were apparently a cab driver for a brief period of your life. And in the story you were trying to catch a cab, and the driver of the taxi basically asks you where you want to go before he lets you into the cab. Right, because in New York, at around 3.30 or 4.00 in the afternoon, the cabs are heading home.
你会确保他们一路与你同行。你的书里有一个精彩的故事，讲述了你试图打车的一刻。我关于你不太了解的事情之一是，显然在你20多岁的时候，在你生命中做过的众多事情中，你显然在生命中的一小段时间里当过出租车司机。在故事中，你试图打车，而出租车司机基本上在你上车之前问你想去哪里。没错，因为在纽约，大约下午3点30分或4点，出租车都在回家。
The shift is over, and they don't want to take you unless you're going somewhere near where their garage is. So I did drive a cab, and I know that the law law is if somebody wants to get in the cab, you have to let them in whether you want to take them or not. So I don't like these conversations about where you're going because I know they're not supposed to ask, they're supposed to take you. So a cab put, now I had been doing all this work when this cab pulled over. And what the improvising work does is it actually builds up your empathy. You get very good at being able to figure out what the other person is going through emotionally.
交接班结束了，除非你要去的地方靠近他们的车库，否则他们不想载你。所以我的确开过出租车，我知道法律规定如果有人想上车，无论你想不想载他们，你都必须让他们上车。所以我不喜欢这些关于你要去哪里的对话，因为我知道他们不该问，他们应该载你。所以一辆出租车停了下来，而我当时正在做所有这些即兴创作的工作。即兴创作的工作实际上增强了你的同理心。你非常擅长弄清楚对方在情感上经历了什么。
So now this cab driver pulls over, he says, where are you going? And I start to get crazy mad. When am I going, you've got to take me no matter where I'm going. But instead of that, I think, wait a minute. It's the time of day when he's switching shifts. He's got to give the cab to somebody else. I understand why he's saying it. And it helped me accept it.
所以现在这个出租车司机把车停下，他说，你要去哪儿？我开始气得发疯。我去哪儿关你屁事，不管我去哪儿你都得载我。但我想的不是这个，等一下。现在正是他交接班的时间。他必须把车交接给别人。我理解他为什么这么说。这帮我接受了现实。
So I told him where I was going, gave me the address. He said, get in. So I thought him where I was going. It gave me the address. He said, get in. So I thought, OK, so that felt pretty good. And he says, what's the cross-street? And I started to get crazy angry again. He's supposed to know the cross-street. But now I'm all empathized up, you know? So I said, do I'm wait a minute?
所以我告诉了他我要去哪儿，把地址给了他。他说，上车。所以我想，好吧，感觉还不错。然后他说，十字路口是哪条？我又开始气得发疯了。他应该知道十字路口是哪条的。但现在我的同理心已经拉满了，你知道吗？所以我说，等等。
I'm looking it up on my iPhone. I'm helping him out. He said, you know you're a nice person. People get in this cab. They don't care about me at all. I'm really impressed with this. I said, well, thanks. He said, I've been trying to go to the bathroom for the last half hour.
我正在用iPhone查，我在帮他。他说，你知道你是个好人。人们坐上这辆出租车，根本不在乎我。我对这个印象很深。我说，哦，谢谢。他说，我过去半小时一直想上厕所。
I said, well, then just drop me off. Don't take me to the corner. Don't go all the way around the block. He said, no, I'm taking you right where you're going. You're a nice person. The guy he's giving up his kidneys for me. So it the funny thing was the exercises that we do in improv give you a little more empathy. And here was an example that I was using it in real life. and it was helping in the communication
我说，那你就把我放下来好了。别把我送到拐角，别绕着街区转。他说，不，我要把你送到你要去的地方。你是个好人。这家伙简直是要为我两肋插刀了。所以有趣的是，我们在即兴表演中做的练习能给你带来更多同理心。而这就是我在现实生活中使用它的一个例子，它确实有助于沟通。
I had with this guy. I got where I wanted to go. I felt so much better about it. And I've noticed that the more empathy I have, the less annoying other people are. You came up with a very interesting exercise at one point where you were trying to increase and train your own ability to empathize with others. And you came up with the system to actually
我和这家伙进行了交流。我到了我想去的地方。我对此感觉好多了。我注意到，我的同理心越强，其他人就越不烦人。你曾在某个时刻提出过一个非常有趣的练习，你试图增加和训练自己与他人共情的能力。你想出了一个系统，实际上可以
sit down with friends or colleagues. What did you do? Well, I realized I couldn't constantly be going to improv exercises. And I noticed that my empathy would sort of wane after a while. This is, we live stressful lives. And one scientist told me that she felt that stress, you know, the stress hormones in your body,
和朋友或同事坐在一起。你做了什么？嗯，我意识到我不可能一直去做即兴表演练习。我注意到我的同理心过一段时间就会减弱。这是因为我们生活在压力重重的环境中。一位科学家告诉我，她认为压力，你知道的，你体内的压力荷尔蒙，
when they build up, they kind of damp your empathy, to some extent. So I had to find a way to build it up again, because I'm beginning to really like being more empathic. So I thought it has to do with relating to other people. So suppose I go through the day, and people I run into like a cashier at a diner, or people that I'm friendly with, and if I spend more than a few seconds with them,
当它们积聚时，会在某种程度上抑制你的同理心。所以我必须找到一种方法再次建立它，因为我开始真的很喜欢变得更有同理心。所以我想这与人际关系有关。假设我度过这一天，我遇到的人，比如餐馆的收银员，或者我熟悉的人，如果我和他们相处超过几秒钟，
while we're talking, I try to figure out what they're feeling or what they're going through. What's their perspective? Where do they stand inside their head? And I would find I'd get a little more opened up to them. And that's what happened by the time I talked to that cab driver, I've been practicing this so much that I actually wasn't angry with him anymore.
在我们交谈时，我试着去弄清楚他们的感受或他们正在经历什么。他们的观点是什么？他们在自己心里是怎么想的？我发现自己会对他们更加敞开心扉。这就是我跟那个出租车司机说话时的情景，我已经练习了这么多次，以至于我真的不再生他的气了。
And I noticed that it seems to happen even if I don't name the emotion. I thought it would be important to name the emotion. And I guess that does, because you can't always name the emotion, you don't really know for sure, but maybe making the effort to name it Put you in touch with them better, but I also notice if I'm just noticing the color of their eyes and taking it and you have very nice brown eyes
我注意到，似乎即使我不说出情绪的名字，它也会发生。我以为说出情绪的名字很重要。我想确实如此，因为你不能总是说出情绪的名字，你并非真的百分之百确定，但也许努力去说出它能让你更好地了解他们，但我也注意到，如果我只是注意他们眼睛的颜色，然后接受它——你有一双非常漂亮的棕色眼睛——
Thank you. I didn't notice that till now And you know it took me about a half an hour before I knew you had a beard You know, it took me about a half an hour before and knew you had a beard. It's which is proof to me that we all can improve on letting each other in. Because you can talk to some, I know in my experience, I'll be talking to somebody for 10 minutes and I'll say, are you really looking at this person?
谢谢。我直到现在才注意到这一点。你知道，我花了大约半小时才知道你留了胡子。你知道，我花了大约半小时才发现你留了胡子。这对我来说证明了我们所有人都可以提高彼此的包容度。因为你可以和某人交谈，据我所知，我会和某人交谈10分钟，然后我会想，你真的在看着这个人吗？
And I realize there's a blob where the face ought to be. And that doesn't help connect with the other person because I think when I really see you, I think something changes on my face. I think I get a little more focused on you and a little more related. And then I see something change on your face. I think it's a dynamic interaction where you're changed by how I'm changed and it goes on and on like that. And we have a much better chance of getting together on what we're talking about. And by our connecting, the people watching us have a greater incentive, a greater impulse to pay attention to us. Because when two people are relating,
我意识到脸该在的地方只有一个模糊的轮廓。这无助于与另一个人建立联系，因为我认为当我真正看到你时，我的脸上会发生一些变化。我认为我更加专注于你，也更能产生共鸣。然后我看到你的脸发生了变化。我认为这是一种动态互动，你的改变会改变我，如此循环往复。我们有更好的机会就我们正在讨论的事情达成一致。通过我们的连接，观看我们的人会有更大的动力、更大的冲动来关注我们。因为当两个人产生联系时，
it's hard not to look at them. Alan Alder's book is called, if I understood you what I have this look on my face, my adventures in the art and science of relating and communicating. Our conversation today was taped before a live audience at the Edelawage Jewish Community Center of Washington, DC. Alan Alder, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
很难不看着他们。阿兰·阿尔达的书名为《如果我理解了你，我脸上会有这种表情吗：我在人际交往和沟通艺术与科学中的冒险》。我们今天的对话是在华盛顿特区埃德尔瓦奇犹太社区中心面对现场观众录制的。阿兰·阿尔达，感谢你今天来到Hidden Brain。
Thank you. Applause Applause This episode was produced by Maggie Penman and Tara Boyle, themselves excellent communicators. Our staff includes Prat Shaw, Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt and Renee Clark. Our Ronsang heroes this week are Shirley Seratsky, Emily Jilson and Elliot Lanes of the JCC.
谢谢。掌声。本期节目由玛吉·彭曼和塔拉·博伊尔制作，他们本身就是优秀的沟通者。我们的团队包括普拉特·肖、雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特和雷妮·克拉克。我们本周的无名英雄是来自JCC的雪莉·塞拉茨基、艾米莉·吉尔森和埃利奥特·莱恩斯。
Shirley, Elliot and Emily helped us tape our conversation with Alan Alda. At one point, while we were playing video clips from Alan's acting career, we had some technical difficulties with the projector. It wouldn't turn off after playing the clips. So surely held a cardboard UPS mail-er in front of that projector for the next 60 minutes to ensure the audience wasn't distracted by a square box of light over the stage. If that isn't the selfless act of an unsung hero, I don't know what is. For more Hidden Brain follow the show on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this show, please communicate it to
雪莉、埃利奥特和艾米莉帮助我们录制了与阿兰·阿尔达的对话。有一次，在我们播放阿兰演艺生涯的视频剪辑时，投影仪出了一些技术故障。播放剪辑后它无法关闭。因此，雪莉在投影仪前举了一个硬纸板UPS邮寄信封60分钟，以确保观众不会被舞台上方发光的方形光盒分散注意力。如果这不算无名英雄的无私行为，我不知道什么才算。想了解更多Hidden Brain，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注本节目，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这个节目，请把它告诉
a friend, tell people about Hidden Brain and ask them to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vidantan and this is NPR. to our show. I'm Shankar Vitanton and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个朋友，向人们介绍Hidden Brain并请他们订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。到我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。